How do I know if mistletoe IVs would be beneficial for bone metastasis?
You recommended osteocate, but is there any other ways to protect my bones other than
exemia?
So the exemia type drugs that are out there, I am not fan of.
So the reason why I'm out of phantom is you can even google these studies.
It has been shown because these drugs have been out long enough now that they don't actually
prevent fractures. They actually increase the density of the periosteum of the bone,
which is the outer part of the bone. You really want the inner part of the bone called the endosteum
increased. So when you have metastasis to bone, as I stated, metastasis to bone is almost always
meaning that it's gobbling up causing damage to the bone, causing what's often referred to
in radiology terminology as rat bite lesions. So it looks like that rat was chewing on your bone.
You have this loss of bone density. And it's through the periosteum but into the endosteum.
So the endosteum is what really gives your bones a strike. It's the calcium
and minerals in the endosteum. Not the periosteum. So the drugs that are out there, they don't have
anything that will help increase the density of the endosteum. The drug does not exist for that.
You know what the best drug quote unquote does is for that is the right source of calcium with
mk4. So mk4 is a type of vitamin K that is found in that product osteocate. That's what I
recommended for you. So osteocate has the right form of calcium, not too high of a dose,
and the mk4 in a very high dose. So you need that very high dose of mk4 to get calcium into the endosteum.
Problem is if you take xevia type products is that you increase the density of the periosteum.
And therefore you're like it has been referred to as you wrapping cellophane or saran wrap around
your bones, which doesn't allow calcium and minerals to be deposited into the endosteum.
And all it is doing is creating a hard brittle bone. It's not decreasing the chance of fracture.
So I don't like those drugs and anybody who studies any of the research does not like those drugs.
Why do they keep recommending them? Because they're like $10,000 a shot and they're big money makers.
I'm sorry, but that's just the truth. And if any of those doctors did their research,
they would not ever take those shots themselves. They wouldn't take that drug. They wouldn't.
I don't know if mistletoe IVs would be beneficial, I test for those. So that didn't come up to your test.
We have some people that say I just feel like no matter what to do something, you're totally welcome
to do that too. So I'm all for the concept of mistletoe in the concept of mistletoe IVs and injection.
So if you feel like God's leading that direction, you know, listen to your to what God's leading you to do.